RONALD SMITH: You did
a lab this week, and it
was a little bit--
the weather discombobulated
us a little bit.
There was fog hanging around.
And some of you got
a good launch.
Some of you didn't.
For those that didn't, depending
on what your TA
wants to do, there may be
another chance to do a launch
when you come to the
second meeting for
that lab next week.
But remember, there are
two parts to that lab.
You have to do the pilot balloon
launch, but you also
have to learn about how to
handle National Weather
Service balloon launches.
So you have to be sure you get
both of those parts done in
the two periods when you
meet for this lab.
So the exam, 10 questions.
You've got two more exams like
this coming in the course.
They'll be a similar structure,
a mixture of short
problems to work out and
short written answers.
They are a little bit long,
as you noticed.
I'll try not to make
them any longer.
But it is what it is.
The average grade on this
I believe was 81.
If you got anywhere in that
vicinity, plus or minus 10, I
wouldn't worry about it.
If you fell way below that, you
might want to talk to me
about how you're handling your
work in the course, whether
you're putting your emphasis
into the right areas of
study and so on.
I'd be happy to talk to
anybody about that.
I'm going to go over each
question today, and if you
have any additional questions
while I go through these,
please stop me, and we'll
spend some time on them.
Question one was about computing
the total mass of
Venus' atmosphere.
And we're going to use the same
principle we used to do
the Earth's atmosphere
in class.
We use the hydrostatic relation
for the full column,
which says that the pressure at
the bottom of the column is
balancing the weight of
the air above it.
So by looking at the ratio of
pressure to gravity, you can
get the mass per unit area in
a column of atmosphere.
And then just multiply
that times the
surface area of the sphere.
So the formula is this, but
you've got to be sure you use
Venus parameters everywhere--
Venus radius, Venus
surface pressure,
Venus surface gravity--
and then you get that number.
Can someone check in their
notes, when we did this for
Earth, what did we find for the
total mass of the Earth's
atmosphere?
Could someone just remind
me of that?
I wanted to do that comparison,
but I don't have
my notes here.
A similar calculation, but we
did it for Earth in class.
STUDENT: 5.4 times
10 to the 17th.
PROFESSOR: 5.4 times 10
to the 17th.
Yeah, so that's quite
a bit less, then.
And that's remarkable that
Venus, one of our nearest
neighbors, has an atmosphere
that is so much more
massive than ours.
So it's not possible to assume
that all these planets have a
similar atmosphere when you see
that kind of a remarkable
difference between just
Venus and Earth.
Any questions on this?
Question two was about
water vapor.
It had two parts, first to
compute the partial pressure
of water vapor.
And I gave you the density--
the mass density of water vapor,
and I gave you the
temperature.
So you should have used the
perfect gas law for that.
I've written it here.
The partial pressure for water
is the density for water times
the gas constant for water
times the temperature.
And you're given 0.01 kilograms
per cubic meter for
the density, but now you've got
to be assured you use the
right gas constant.
So the gas constant for water
is going to be the universal
gas constant, 8,314,
divided by the
molecular weight for water.
Water is H2O.
The molecular weight of
oxygen is about 16.
The molecular weight of each
hydrogen atom is 1, so that
adds up to 18.
That's why I have it there.
So I've brought that value down
into here, 462 for the
gas constant.
And then of course I had to
convert the temperature, which
was 20 Celsius, to Kelvin,
and that's what you get.
And be sure to put units.
Always have units on there.
That'll be Pascals if you're
following the normal
SI system of units.
The relative humidity is the
ratio of the partial pressure
of water vapor to the saturation
value at the
temperature that you have. And
there's a table here that
gives you a few values for
saturation vapor pressure for
water at given temperatures.
And for 20 degrees, it's
23.4 millibars.
Got to keep consistent units.
We're working in Pascals, so I
divided by 2,340, and I get
0.58, which is 58%.
A couple of you put not P Sat
down here but P Total, the
total pressure, air
plus water vapor.
Well, that's going to be much,
much larger than this value.
The total pressure, for example,
in this room, P
Total, would be something like
1,013 millibars, two more
zeroes to get it in Pascals.
And if I put that number into
there, I'm going to get a very
much smaller relative
humidity.
But that'd be missing
the point.
Relative humidity is not the
ratio of water to air.
It's the ratio of how much water
you have to how much
water vapor you can have, the
maximum that you can have at
the temperature that
you're given.
Is that clear?
Question three, explain why
clouds form in rising air.
Well, the point is that clouds
form when air rises, because
when air rises, it moves
to lower pressure.
Pressure decreases as you
go up in the atmosphere.
When you put air into a lower
pressure, it'll expand.
When air expands, it does work
on its environment, and its
temperature drops.
That's called adiabatic
cooling.
When you cool air, its
saturation vapor pressure
drops-- that is, the amount that
can be held in the vapor
state decreases--
and if that continues, then
eventually, the relative
humidity will reach 100%
and then go beyond.
And the excess, then, must
condense out as liquid or ice,
some form of condensed water.
So the idea for the answer to
that has to do with adiabatic
cooling and the decrease in the
saturation vapor pressure
because of that cooling.
Questions on that?
The greenhouse effect, why does
it warm rather than cool
the surface of the planet?
The point is that the greenhouse
effect has to do
with atmospheres absorbing some
fraction of the radiation
that's trying to penetrate
through it.
Now, that's a good starting
statement, but we've got to
get more specific than that.
It turns out that it's easier
for the Sun's rays to get in
than it is for the Earth
radiation to get out.
If it were the opposite, then
I suppose the greenhouse
effect would be a cooling
mechanism, making it difficult
for the Sun's rays to get in.
But if it's easy for the Earth's
radiation to get out,
that probably would cool.
But it doesn't.
So easy to get in, difficult
to get out, therefore, the
Earth's temperature must warm
in order to reach that
radiative balance.
So what makes it easier to
get in than to get out?
It's not the direction.
It's the wavelength.
The wavelength of the radiation
coming from the Sun
is centered around--
in the visible range, about
0.4 to 0.7 microns.
And because of the gases we have
in the atmosphere, the
particular gases, the
atmosphere is mostly
transparent to those
wavelengths.
On the other hand, the Earth's
surface being cooler, when it
radiates, it radiates at
a longer wavelength.
And for those wavelengths, the
atmosphere is mostly opaque.
So that's why the greenhouse
effect is there.
And quite a few of you had a
garbled explanation of that.
What gases contribute and why?
So it turns out that none of
the molecules we define as
being air molecules--
that is, N2, O2, and argon--
none of them are active
greenhouse gases.
Their structure is too simple.
They don't have a dipole moment,
and they cannot absorb
or emit the infrared
radiation.
But slightly more complex
molecules, like CO2, water
vapor, ozone, N2O, NO, they
have enough of a complex
structure--
mostly asymmetry.
They break symmetry in a way
that allows them to have a
positive-charged end and
a negative-charged end.
And that means that they've got
a dipole, and they can--
just like your cell phone, they
can emit and they can
absorb radiation using that
oscillating dipole.
Questions on that?
Question five, a small
rocky asteroid.
OK, I give you the
solar constant--
that's how much radiation
is reaching that--
and I give you its albedo.
So what are you going to do?
Here's the thing here.
So if you've got this little
asteroid, it's got a certain
value of the solar constant.
It's going to be different for
Earth, because it's closer to
the Sun, so the solar constant's
going to be a
little bit larger.
Really, you've got
to make the same
assumption we made in class.
You're going to have to assume
that you've reached some kind
of a steady-state temperature,
where it's receiving an amount
of radiation per unit of time
and emitting at the
same rate to space.
And then you've got to find the
temperature of the object
that allows it to be in that
steady-state balance.
If the temperature's too cold,
it won't be radiating enough
to be in steady-state.
If it's too hot, it'll be
radiating too much to be in
steady state.
So there's only one temperature
that'll allow it
to balance its heat, and that's
the one that you can
derive from this formula.
So solar constant, 1 minus the
albedo, over 4 times the
Stefan-Boltzmann constant.
So 2,000 watts per square meter,
1 minus the albedo, 4--
there's the Stefan-Boltzmann
constant--
take the fourth root, 257 K.
Any questions on that?
I think people did pretty
well on that one.
Question six, explain why a
planet like Earth will have
lost its light gases over
geologic time but retained its
heavier gases.
So the point is the Earth is
in this middle category of
planets where it's large enough
to retain the heavier
gases but not large enough to
retain the light gases.
And the way one reasons that
out is to realize that the
Earth has a certain
escape velocity--
that's the velocity needed
for particles to escape--
and that is independent of
the particle itself.
That's just a fixed value.
Then the light molecules
are moving rapidly.
The heavier molecules are
moving more slowly.
And it turns out that enough
of the light molecules are
exceeding the escape velocity,
so we will have lost that over
geologic time.
But the heavier molecules are
moving slowly enough, so they
do not exceed the escape
velocity, and they can be
retained gravitationally
by the planet.
So most of you got that, while a
few of you buggered up those
descriptions a little bit.
Question seven was just
a-- here it is--
it's just a cloud.
The earth is radiating, and the
cloud top is radiating.
The temperature of the Earth I
gave you as plus 30, and this
was minus 60.
And I just asked you to compare
how these two surfaces
are radiating to space.
The two things you had to do,
you had to compute the
wavelength that was being
most strongly
emitted by each surface.
Each surface emits a broad
range of wavelengths, but
there's a peak where it emits
more than at other
wavelengths.
And that's given by Wien's
Law, which is here.
So for the higher
temperature--
this is the constant divided by
the temperature in Kelvin--
it comes out to be
9.56 microns.
And for the cooler temperature,
it's at about
13.6 microns.
But both of those fall
into the thermal
infrared range of radiation.
And in terms of the flux, how
much radiation is being
emitted, it's the
Stefan-Boltzmann Law.
Again, put in the temperatures
in Kelvin, and
you get 483 and 118.
A big difference arises because
of that powerful power
of four in the exponent there.
Questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: I just have a question
about significant figures.
So I know when you emailed us
that one time, you said to
give us back one more
significant figure
than you gave us.
So I think I got some points off
for that, but if you only
gave us one significant figure,
would I give an answer
back with two?
PROFESSOR: One or two
would be my
recommendation.
So here, I'm not sure
I've been completely
consistent with that.
For example, when I gave you
the temperature on that
problem, I just gave it to
you as kind of a round
number, 30 and 60.
So that's not many significant
figures.
On the other hand, the constants
are known to, in
fact, many more than this.
I've truncated that a bit too.
So you do have a bit
of a dilemma there.
Do you go with-- here, there's
four significant figures.
Here, I gave it to
you in Celsius.
There was only maybe
one or two.
By the time I convert that to
Kelvin, it looks like maybe
there's now three.
So, yeah, this is tricky.
And I hope we weren't unfair.
But if you were going to give me
five or six decimal points
there, I would have
taken off credit.
Or if you'd truncated that off
to be, you know, 480 or
something, I probably would have
taken off some credit.
But if you're anywhere in this
ballpark, I hope we didn't.
But show that to me if there's
a problem with that.
I think we can go on to
question eight, then.
So this was one of those release
of a pollutant in an
unconfined atmosphere
with no wind.
It says there's no
wind blowing.
So I imagine a source that's
diffusing out in all three
directions--
north, south, and upwards--
forming a growing hemisphere
of polluted air.
And the radius of that
hemisphere is growing with
time according to the
square root of the
diffusivity times time.
And so putting the numbers
in we had for that--
be sure you work in seconds--
I get 1,039 meters.
And then the way I did the
problem was to compute the
mass of air in that
hemisphere.
So that's the density of air
times the volume of the
hemisphere.
And I got 2.8 times 10 to the 9
kilograms. Sorry, kilograms.
And then this concentration
we're looking for is the mass
of the pollutant divided by the
mass of the air into which
it has been mixed.
And I said you put in 10 tons,
I think, so that's 10 to the
fourth kilograms divided by
2.8 times 10 to the ninth
kilograms, just this number
brought down, and I got 3.57
times 10 to the minus six.
In mass units, kilograms
per kilogram.
So noticing the minus six, I
could write that as 3.57 parts
per million--
there's the million--
by mass.
By mass because it's kilograms
per kilogram.
So that's what I got for that.
Questions there?
People did well on nine.
I just gave the--
I reminded you of the lapse rate
for Earth, and I gave you
the height of 30 kilometers.
You had to put it into this
approximate formula for an
isothermal atmosphere, and you
got that for a mass density at
that elevation in units of
kilograms per cubic meter.
All right, the last one, then.
Supercooled water is liquid
water at a temperature below
the normal freezing point of
water-- that is, below zero
degrees Celsius.
It typically has the property
that it wants to freeze, and
if something comes along that
will give it that chance,
it'll freeze instantaneously.
But until you do that,
it will stay for a
while as liquid water.
Unstable lapse rate.
An unstable lapse rate is an
atmospheric lapse rate--
which, as you know, is the
rate at which temperature
changes with height, that's a
definition of a lapse rate--
that is more negative than
the adiabatic value.
The dry adiabatic
value is minus
9.8 degrees per kilometer.
So if it's more negative than
that, that would mean, for
example, minus 10, minus 11,
minus 12 degrees Celsius per
kilometer would be an
unstable lapse rate.
If it's less negative or
positive, like minus five
degrees per kilometer, minus
two, minus one, zero, plus
two, plus five, those would
all be stable lapse rates.
And the characteristic of that
is that when a parcel rises,
then, it cools less rapidly than
the environment in which
it's penetrating.
And therefore, it ends up
warmer than its new
environment.
And that'll allow it to continue
to rise, and it'll
lead to convection if
you try to set up an
unstable lapse rate.
Archimedes' Law, few
of you got this.
I guess it's because it's not
in the book, and I only
mentioned it once in class.
But still I was a little bit
surprised, because I think
it's well known.
But the Archimedes' Law I'm
referring to here is that the
buoyancy force that acts on an
object immersed in a fluid is
equal to the weight of
the fluid displaced.
So if I take a basketball and I
push it down into a swimming
pool, I will feel a force trying
to push it back up
that's equal to the weight of
the water that would be there
if the ball were not.
Now, that turns out to be pretty
simple to understand,
because the pressure increases
as you go down in that pool,
and therefore, the bottom of
the basketball feels higher
pressure than the top.
And that's what's causing
the buoyancy force.
And the rate at which that
pressure increases as you go
down is related to the density
of the surrounding fluid.
That's why the surrounding fluid
comes in, because the
surrounding fluid determines
the rate at which pressure
increases with depth.
And it's that increase that
gives you the buoyancy force
pushing up on the ball.
So that's Archimedes' Law.
The tropopause is the boundary
between the troposphere and
the stratosphere.
The troposphere is that first
layer where the temperature
normally decreases
with height.
The stratosphere is the next one
up where the temperature
increases with height.
Advection fog is fog caused by
moving warm air-- warm, moist
air over a cold surface.
Advection means horizontal
movement.
So that's a clue.
And if you take warm, moist air
and move it over a cold
surface, it's going to lose
heat to that surface.
As it cools down, the saturation
vapor pressure's
going to drop.
And the familiar story, you're
going to form some condensed
water droplets in that way,
and that's the fog.
Questions on any of that?
Sorry to take so long on that,
but I want to just be clear
that you should spend some
time going over those.
If you want to do better on the
next one, part of the key
is to really go over the last
one and understand everything
that you did and how you
could have done better.
Let's see here.
It'll be just a minute for
that light to come on.
I want to start a new subject
today, which is the general
circulation of the atmosphere.
There it is.
So we just finished a big
section on water in the
atmosphere, so this is
a new topic now.
We're going to look at the
whole globe and try to
understand the large-scale
air motions on the globe.
I always have a debate
with myself at this
point of the course.
I wonder whether I should start
with the smaller-scale
air motions like storms and then
talk about the general
circulation, or whether I
should do the general
circulation first. And I never
know quite the answer.
This year, we're going to start
with general circulation
first, then do storms. But then
as we get into seasons,
we'll have to come back to
review this subject of the
general circulation
of the atmosphere.
So the basic principles that
are going to control how we
think about this problem is
that differential heating
generates the circulation.
Now, you know this.
If I have a bonfire over here
or a hot stove or something,
it's going to heat
the air near it.
That warm air wants to rise
because of its buoyancy, and
you're going to set up a
circulation in this room
driven by the fact that
you're heating the air
here but not there.
Differential heating means
you're applying different
heating at different
locations.
But that circulation, then,
is going to move heat--
because the air carries heat
with it, it's going to move
heat from hot to cold regions
trying to balance out the
local heat budgets.
So we're going to see this
principle applied now to the
atmosphere as a whole.
And you can imagine starting
with just this simple idea.
Here's the globe, and the Sun
hits the equatorial regions
most directly.
In the equatorial regions in the
middle of the day, the Sun
is directly overhead.
So this cosine theta factor
is about one.
You're getting the full
intensity of the Sun, 1,380
watts per square meter, directly
hitting regions near
the Equator.
And it turns out that there's
less thermal radiation being
emitted in the equatorial
regions than is being received
from the Sun.
So while we assumed a week or
so ago that the Earth as a
whole is in radiative balance,
that is not true for each
latitude belt.
Each latitude belt is out of a
state of radiative balance.
As I've shown here near the
Equator, getting more from the
Sun than it's emitting to space,
and at the poles, where
the radiation is coming in
tangentially, you're really
getting very little sunlight.
Of course, with the tilt of the
Earth, you do get a little
bit, but let's assume that ray
is just parallel here.
It's just going to hit the
North Pole tangentially.
It's not going to deliver any
solar energy that way.
But the temperature of the pole
is not absolute zero, so
it will be radiating to space.
So there's an imbalance here.
There's an excess of heat
here and a heat
deficit near the poles.
How can that be sustained?
Well, the way that is sustained
is to have some
other mechanism for transporting
the heat from the
Equator to the pole.
And that's where the general
circulation comes in.
So not only is the difference in
heating going to produce a
circulation by buoyancy forces,
but that circulation
then is going to solve this
problem we have of how to
balance out the heat budget
at each latitude.
So there's two ways to
look at this problem.
Differential heating causes
the circulation, and the
circulation helps us to balance
the heat budget at
each latitude.
I'm going to go through this
now in some detail, because
this is the key concept for
understanding the Earth's
general circulation.
So on the x-axis is latitude
from the North Pole down to
the Equator to the South Pole.
And there are two curves here.
The red curve is radiation
received from the Sun.
That could be over a day or
over a year, averaged out.
But anyway, there's a lot of
radiation being received from
the Sun in the equatorial
region and much,
much less at the poles.
I brought the globe over here
just to remind you of this.
If I forget the tilt for the
moment and the Sun's radiation
is coming in like this and the
Earth is spinning-- let me get
it spinning in the right
direction, it
spins towards the east--
you're going to get a lot of
heat distributed around the
globe near the Equator.
But the Sun's rays
are just coming
tangentially near the poles.
So on a per unit area basis, you
get very little radiation
near the poles.
Now, that's probably
an annual average.
And during Northern Hemisphere
summertime with this tilt, OK,
there is a little
bit of radiation
received at the pole.
In the Northern Hemisphere
winter,
there's absolutely none.
So you don't get a zero value.
You get something that's an
average of the seasons.
But it's definitely much less
than what is received at the
Equator, just because of the
geometry of the sphere.
It's nothing more than just the
geometry of the sphere and
the fact that the Sun's
rays are coming in
parallel to each other.
Now, the equatorial regions
are warmer than the other
parts of the planet, so they
radiate more by the
Stefan-Boltzmann Law.
I have it right here.
The hotter the surface, the
more it radiates, but not
enough to make up
that difference.
So there is a heat surplus
near the Equator.
Near the poles, it radiates less
than at the equator, but
not so much less that it doesn't
leave a deficit there.
So we've got this problem of how
to balance the budget in
the Equator and in the
high-latitude regions.
And that is done, as I've said
before now, by a heat transfer
mechanism that has to do with
the ocean and the atmosphere
transporting heat to the
poles to balance
out that heat budget.
So here's what we estimate from
what we know about the
atmosphere using balloon
soundings and so on
to work this out.
What's plotted here on the
x-axis is the heat
transport in watts--
it's a power unit--
as a function of latitude.
North Pole, Equator,
South Pole.
And the total is shown in the
black curve, the atmospheric
component in red, and
the ocean in blue.
Now, something about
the units.
It says capital P, capital
P capital W up there.
The capital of the P means
"peta." You know the prefixes
"kilo" and "mega" and "giga"
and "tera." Well, you keep
going up till you get to peta,
which is 10 to the 15th.
So a petawatt is 10
to the 15th watts.
So for example, at a
latitude of about
30 or 40 north latitude--
and New Haven is right here at
40 north, just about in the
peak of this curve--
there is about six petawatts
of energy being transported
towards the North Pole by ocean
and air currents in the
atmosphere.
Most of it's by air currents.
Now, do we know this?
When we walk outside today,
do we know this?
Well, I would argue that, yes,
you probably do know this.
Because from your experience
now, you know that on days
when it's especially warm,
the air is blowing
from the south, typically.
On days when it's especially
cold, the air is
blowing from the north.
So there's this transport
of air back and forth.
You have roughly the same amount
of air moving north and
south, but when it's moving
northward, it is--
you can put that down on
the floor, if you like.
Sorry it's in your way.
When it's blowing northward,
it's carrying more heat,
because it's hotter.
And when it's flying southward,
it's carrying less
heat, because it's colder.
So just from that asymmetry
that you would notice on a
day-by-day basis, you can
understand what's causing this
north-south heat transport.
It's just air moving back and
forth, but carrying more heat
on its way north than it
does on its way south.
I'm going to illustrate that
first for the ocean.
This is a crude diagram of the
gyres in each of the world's
ocean basins.
For example, in the North
Atlantic gyre, there is a warm
current going northward.
That's the Gulf Stream, shown in
red to indicate that it's a
warm current.
There's a cold current
running southwards.
So look.
You're taking the same amount
of water north and south.
You're not piling up water at
the pole or at the Equator,
but you are transporting
a net amount of heat--
not a net amount of water, but
yes, a net amount of heat.
Because the water going
northwards is warm.
The water moving southwards
is cold.
So they don't balance each other
out in terms of the heat
that they're carrying.
And the same thing goes on in
the Southern Hemisphere.
For example, there are warm
currents and cold currents, so
the net heat transport
is towards the south.
That's why they plotted this
negative on the last plot.
So if we call this plot the
northward heat transport, it's
positive in the Northern
Hemisphere, because you're
transporting heat towards
the North Pole.
It's negative in the Southern
Hemisphere, because you're
transporting heat towards the
South Pole, going in the
opposite direction, so we give
it a negative sign like that.
So the oceans are doing some of
it, but the atmosphere does
most of it.
Typically, if you have warm air
and cold air and the jet
stream is running around the
Earth kind of in a zonally
symmetric fashion, well
then, you're not
transporting any heat.
But very frequently, it'll break
down into a wave-like
motion, where cold air will come
streaming down-- in fact,
here's New Haven right
about here--
cold air will come streaming
down from the pole, heading to
the Equator.
That has to be replaced by an
equal amount of warm air
moving poleward.
And in so doing, you'll have a
net amount of heat transported
towards the pole, and that's
what'll balance out the heat
budget at each latitude.
Just to remind you about this
basic physical principle, if
you imagine a pipe carrying
a fluid, what do you
know about the pipe?
You probably know the
cross-sectional area of the
pipe, you know the speed of the
fluid in the pipe, and you
probably know the density of
the fluid in the pipe.
Then if you wanted to
know the mass flux--
how much water or how
much air is being
carried by that pipe--
it's simply the product rho UA,
and that'll have units of
kilograms per second.
That'll be a mass flow rate.
Well, its only a small step--
once you understand that, it's
only a small step to go beyond
that to understand how
much heat is being
transported in the pipe.
Because we know the heat
capacity or the heat stored in
a fluid is proportional to the
mass that you have times the
specific heat capacity times
the temperature.
So this quantity C sub p--
I've given the value
here for air--
it's called the specific heat
capacity at constant pressure.
You can look it up.
You can Google it.
It has this value for air.
The units here are joules per
kilogram per degree Kelvin.
So the more mass you have,
the more heat is stored.
And the hotter the temperature,
the more mass is
[correction: energy]
stored in a particular
kilogram of air.
So to go from the mass flux to
the heat flux, you just have
to multiply by these additional
two factors, the
heat capacity, which is the
amount of heat you have per
degree of temperature, and then
the temperature itself.
STUDENT: And so what are
the units on heat flux?
PROFESSOR: The units on heat
flux would be
joules per second.
Or you may know that
that is a watt.
A joule per second is a watt.
So the point is that when air
moves, heat moves too, because
heat is stored in air.
Now, this doesn't quite
convey the full
picture I want to convey.
If I went back to this picture,
what I'd like you to
envision is two of
these pipes.
One's carrying air southward,
and the other is carrying an
equal amount of air
mass northwards.
The amount of mass flow in each
pipe is the same, but the
amount of heat flow is not,
because the temperature is
different for the two pipes.
So no net transport of
mass, but yes, a net
transport of heat.
Because one stream of air is
cold, and the other stream of
air is hot.
So I don't think this is a
particularly difficult
concept, but it lies at the base
of understanding how the
atmospheric general
circulation works.
Are there questions on this?
I'd love to take a minute
or two on questions.
Yes.
STUDENT: Why does that happen?
Why does it not stay constant?
PROFESSOR: I'll get to the
question of why
that happens in about a week.
This happens because of an
instability that occurs along
the jet stream that generates
what's called a mid-latitude
frontal cyclone.
It's the main weather producer
around the mid latitudes.
And over the next six months,
your life will be largely
controlled by these events.
Storms that come through
New Haven are
mid-latitude frontal cyclones.
They are basically breakouts.
The prison boundary has been
breached, and the cold air is
breaking out and going south,
and the warm air is heading
northwards when the jet stream
develops a little instability
in it and breaks down
in that way.
So your book is good at
talking about these
mid-latitude frontal cyclones,
and we'll be talking about it
in this course as well.
It's a spontaneous event.
It happens throughout the
winter, just day after day
after day, just one after the
other of these kind of
breakout events.
Now, the subject gets a little
more complicated, though,
because of the effect of
the Earth's rotation.
Remember, I'm talking
about the Earth
spinning on its axis.
And what does that do?
Well, there's one obvious thing
it does and one perhaps
that's not so obvious.
The obvious one is that
it distributes
the Sun's heat zonally.
So if I just had this globe
sitting fixed without spinning
and the Sun was over there, it's
hitting this side of the
Earth, but never this side.
And so we'd have a hot spot
forming here, and this would
be icy cold on the other side.
Instead, because the Earth is
spinning on its axis, it's not
a hot spot that forms, but a
hot region near the Equator
that forms. The spinning
of it distributes
the Sun's heat zonally.
We use the word "zonally"
when we're going this
way around the Earth.
And you end up with
a latitudinal--
or sometimes we say
"meridional"--
temperature gradient,
or heating gradient.
But zonally, the heat gets well
distributed because of
the spinning of the Earth.
So that's the first point.
The other one that we'll
get to next week is
the Coriolis force.
Whenever a planet spins,
it generates a somewhat
mysterious new force called
the Coriolis force.
Whenever a parcel tries to move
in a straight line on a
spinning planet, it
gets deflected.
And we're going to talk
about that next time.
And that really has a major
influence on the nature of the
general circulation,
as we will see.
And I'll give you a hint of
that here, and we'll do it
more quantitatively next week.
So for example, let's look at
the case when the planet is
not rotating.
So the point that's right under
the Sun, if the Sun's
down there, would heat up.
And every other place, you'd
get less and less sunlight.
Whether you moved this way or
that way, you'd get less and
less sunlight, and you'd get no
sunlight on the backside.
So you'd have a subsolar hot
spot, just one very hot area
right here.
The low-level air would
move in towards it.
Those are the red arrows.
And then, because the air gets
heated, it would rise, and
then aloft, it would spread
out in all directions.
And those are the thin
blue arrows.
So that's just like I built
a bonfire here.
You'd have air moving
in towards it from
all directions rising.
And then when it hit the
ceiling, it would go out in
all directions.
Now, this is not at all
what we have on Earth.
This is the idealization or kind
of a thought experiment
of what the circulation would
be if the Earth was not
rotating on its axis.
So don't take this
as what happens.
Take it as a building block to
understand what actually
happens in the Earth's
atmosphere.
So let me bring in now the
effect of distributing the
heat zonally.
So this would happen if
I had weak rotation.
I learned a few weeks ago in
a lecture I went to on the
planet Titan that actually the
planet Titan fits into this
kind of a description.
It rotates rapidly enough to
distribute the heat zonally
but not so rapidly
that the Coriolis
force is a major player.
So here's what happens.
You get a hot equator, a fairly
uniform hot equator.
Air moves towards it at low
levels, gets heated, rises,
and then moves away from it,
poleward, at high elevations.
It would sink somewhere out here
and fall to the surface,
and then move towards the hot
line again, and then rise.
You'd have a kind of planetary,
simple bonfire kind
of circulation towards and away
from this heated line
caused by the solar heat.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Would the surface at
the equator be really hot and
the surface at the poles
be really cold?
PROFESSOR: It'd be cold.
That's right.
And the circulation would be a
rather simple one, rising near
the equator, sinking near the
poles, and then the air moves
right back to the equator.
But now, that's for
weak rotation.
For the Earth, we rotate
somewhat faster than that.
You know it takes 24 hours
for us to have a day.
That's a pretty fast rotation.
By the way, this is sometimes
called the single-cell
circulation.
Well, I guess there's two of
them, but on one side of the
equator, there's just
one, rising,
sinking, rising, sinking.
So the single cell refers to
what happens on either the
northern or the southern
hemisphere.
On Earth, you get something
that's closer to a three-cell
circulation, because the
rotation rate is larger.
So the Coriolis force is
playing a larger role.
You do get rising motion near
the Equator, but it only goes
slightly north and south
and then sinks.
And north of that, you get
westerlies and then easterlies
again, laid out like
I have very crudely
on this line diagram.
I'm going to show you a better
version of this in just a
moment, but the main point
is to show how much more
complicated this is than that.
And that all has to do with
the stronger action of the
Coriolis force.
So this is a more typical
artist conception of the
three-circulation system.
It's a little bit more
complicated, of course.
The rising motion along the
Equator then gives you
poleward-moving air aloft that
descends at about 30 degrees
north and south latitude.
This is a very strong
overturning cell.
It's called the Hadley cell.
And you must know
about this one.
This is really one of the
dominant features of the
climatology on Planet Earth
is the Hadley cell.
Rising motion near the Equator,
air moving poleward
till it gets to about 30 degrees
and then sinks, and
then returns towards
the Equator at the
surface of the Earth.
Because of the deflecting force
from the Coriolis force,
that air doesn't move directly
towards the Equator.
It comes in from the
easterly direction.
So it forms what we call the
northeast trades, wind blowing
from the northeast in the
Northern Hemisphere, and the
southeast trade winds in the
Southern Hemisphere.
North and south of that, there
is the Ferrel cell, which is a
rather weak overturning in
the opposite direction.
But that's not the
primary feature.
I don't like this diagram,
because they show the Ferrel
cell so clearly, but they don't
show the most obvious
and dramatic feature of the
westerlies, and that's the
existence of these mid-latitude
frontal cyclones
that I was talking about
just a moment ago.
And when I show you a movie, you
won't see the Ferrel cell,
but you'll see those
mid-latitude frontal cyclones
in that region.
And then in the polar regions,
you get also a fairly weak
cell giving you some
easterly flow at
the very high latitudes.
So this is the three-cell
pattern of general circulation
for Planet Earth.
And I want to show you a set of
satellite loops to try to
illustrate a few of
these features.
This is a global view pieced
together from a number of
geostationary satellites posted
at various longitudes
around the globe.
And it's looking at the emitted
long-wave radiation.
So we won't see day
and night here.
We're not counting on the Sun
to illuminate these clouds.
If we did that, it would go
black, light, black, light as
the Sun illuminated or not.
But instead, we're looking at
the emitted radiation--
Stefan-Boltzmann-type
emitted radiation
in the thermal infrared--
and that'll tell us about where
the clouds are and where
the clear air is.
For example, these light
areas are clouds.
They're higher, so
they are colder.
They emit less.
Just like the problem you had
on the exam, they emit less
because they're higher.
And that reduction in
emission is shown
here as a white region.
The lower parts and the surface
of the ocean and the
surface of the planet
are hotter.
They emit more.
And that's illustrated
here by a dark pixel.
So you're basically looking at
a moving temperature map of
the Earth, where the
temperature's mostly
controlled by the height of the
object that you're seeing.
The clouds are high,
so they're cold.
The ocean and the land are
low, so they're warm.
I don't think I'll have much
time to talk about this, but I
just want to leave you with this
image of how this moves.
This is three or four days.
And some of the things you see
here are the Intertropical
Convergence Zone, where the
trade winds are converging and
the air is rising.
And then your eye is really
caught by these mid-latitude
frontal cyclones.
I'm going to play that one more
time, and look at all
these little comma-shaped
cloud features here that
represent this rapid flux
of heat northwards and
southwards, trying to balance
the Earth's heat budget
latitude by latitude.
I'll get this to show again.
I'll show it just one more time,
and then we'll quit.
We'll quit there and continue
this discussion next time.